hey guys thanks for joining me again for
those of you don't know me my name is
ava Tomich I'm a masters of architecture
graduate and I'm the founder of y
watches last year I launched at midnight
collection and you guys absolutely loved
it
we're raising the $30,000 in just under
30 days since the launch there's been
one reoccurring request so I'm back on
Kickstarter today to give you guys
exactly what you asked for
style affordability and variety these
are the core elements while watching
this pounded on and the fundamental
characteristics you have supported since
2016 the last Kickstarter campaign
showcased biopsying timepieces with the
metal and mesh band options but
according to all of you it really should
have come with a leather strap option as
well it's created a new challenge plus
one which we solved by using our iconic
wire logo derived from the ladder to
Perth it is a minimalistic through line
design split exactly 31 point 95 degrees
inside North to ensure our strap designs
complemented our timepieces we cut
shaped and tailored a strap from only
premium materials slice the exact same
degree today marks a start of something
special and love for you to be a part of
it below you'll find a variety of
options each with the final pieces of
puzzle as well as a little something
extra together we're about to create the
ultimate collection
[Music]